there goes both our cart estimate as
Courant says the golf plus has an image
as an old people's car but VW is trying
to change that with its successor the
gold sports van it looks small down
there he says but it actually isn't time
to check it out the car makes a good
impression from the very first touch on
the gas pedal
it's young dynamic appearance is backed
up by dynamic handling the golf sport
vans many optional assistance systems
also distance it from its predecessor
they include autonomous cruise control
with emergency braking and a blind spot
assistance that also serves as a parking
assistant one sweet extra is a panoramic
glass roof that costs just over 1200
euros it's a car for all ages
that's avec Monta says the chassis is
excellent in the typical golf style the
new model is also responsive while
shifting is quick with no catches he
gets it good grades all around our test
driver is taking out the top line model
loaded with extras called the Highline
it's 110 kilowatt is I motor consumes
5.6 liters of fuel for every 100
kilometers on the road from a dead stop
it can hit 100 kilometres an hour in
just eight point eight seconds which
makes it fairly sporty the Highline
costs over twenty seven and a half
thousand euros in Germany a pretty hefty
investment but if you buy one you'll
certainly be traveling in comfort its
higher center of gravity is barely
noticeable but the fact that the seed
slit you perch a little farther from the
ground is a positive development Martha
says that the sports van is designed to
provide good field of vision and if you
look to the right and to the left and
out the back they got it right part of
that is due to the new gulfs large
windows which also give it a more
elegant look to increase the amount of
glass on display even more the rear view
mirrors are now mounted on the door the
sports vans fierce and angular front end
appears to be scowling from under
thunderous brows it's a look sure to
appeal to younger buyers sporting a rear
roof spoiler the car also looks
attractive from the back thought of
awesome after his test driving a new
golf montes is ready to check out some
of its other features like his trunk he
thought it was larger than it is but
hold on you can adjust it for size then
default via VW's engineers looked at all
of the legroom available to passengers
in the back and thought they should make
it adjustable the whole thing could
slide forward 18 centimeters says Montes
though that means less legroom but
depending on who is in back if anyone
that might not matter and the extra
space can certainly come in handy in the
trunk
I am kapha home field plots qivana under
cava first line
have it smallest the sports vans trunk
has 500 liters of space but adjusting
the rear seat adds another 90 and if you
lower the rear backrests that increases
to over 1500 litres of space the new
gulfs interior also has something of a
van like character although that doesn't
mean it looks or feels cheap the
materials used in its construction or
high-end and the model offers plenty of
creature comforts they go sports man our
expert says the Golf sportsvan doesn't
just have more amenities and better
safety features than the Golf Plus the
also person likes the much more dynamic
design and sporty suspension and he's
sure younger buyers will like them too
of course strictly speaking the goal
sports van is neither a sports car nor a
van but who are we to quibble about a
car as pleasing as this one after all
what's in a name it's how a car performs
on the street that counts Golf Plus
owners will feel comfortable with the
switch the VW might also attract some
new customers the bare-bones version of
the new Volkswagen costs just over
nineteen and a half thousand euros in
Germany making it affordable even for
young families
you